♪ ♪
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
JOE BIDEN ALREADY TRADING BLOWS
AND WHAT COULD BE A PREVIEW OF A
2020 SHUT ON.
PRESIDENT TRUMP GOING AFTER THE
FORMER VP ON TWITTER SAYING "THE
MEDIA FAKE NEWS IS PUSHING
SLEEPY JOE HARD.
FUNNY.
I AM ONLY HERE BECAUSE OF
JOE BIDEN AND OBAMA.
THEY DIDN'T DO THE JOB, AND NOW
YOU HAVE FROM, WHO IS GETTING IT
DONE BIG TIME."
MEANWHILE, BIDEN HITTING BACK
JUST MOMENTS AGO.
>> I AM MAKING NO POLICIES.
I AM A UNION MAN, PERIOD.
FOLKS, IF I'M GOING TO BE ABLE
TO BE DONALD TRUMP IN 2020, IT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN HERE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
IN PENNSYLVANIA.
>> Juan: THIS COMES AMID A NEW
REPORT THAT MAY EXPLAIN WHY
BIDEN'S 2020 RUN HASN'T BEEN
ADDRESSED BY PRESIDENT OBAMA.
HE TRIED TO TALK BIDEN OUT OF
RUNNING IN 2016 BECAUSE HE
THOUGHT HILLARY CLINTON WAS MORE
ELECTABLE.
KENNEDY, I DON'T KNOW IF THERE
IS ANY DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
IT IS THE DEMOCRATIC
ESTABLISHMENT COALESCED AROUND
HER PRETTY EARLY.
>> Kennedy: YEAH, IT'S SO EASY
AT THIS POINT TO PLAY MONDAY
EVENING QUARTERBACK.
OBVIOUSLY, HILLARY CLINTON WAS
IN THE MOST DELECTABLE CANDIDAT
CANDIDATE, BUT SHE HAD NEARLY
SUCCESSFUL RUN.
BIDEN IS MUCH MORE LOYAL PERSON
BEEN PRESENT UP BOTTOM, AND WE
SEE THAT NOW BECAUSE OBAMA WON'T
EVEN ENDORSE HIS SUPPOSEDLY GOOD
FRIEND.
HIS LOYAL VP, WHO SERVED HIM
PROUDLY FOR EIGHT YEARS.
SO I THINK IT'S AN INTERESTING
DYNAMIC THERE.
AND IT ALSO GOES TO SHOW, AND WE
HAVE SEEN THIS TIME AND TIME
AGAIN, PRESIDENT OBAMA IS REALLY
GOOD AT GETTING HIMSELF ELECTED
IF YOU'RE TERRIBLE AT GETTING
OTHER PEOPLE ELECTED.
>> Juan: JESSE, I THINK LOTS
OF PEOPLE ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE
VIEW THE ESTABLISHMENT AROUND
HILLARY IN 2016 AS A GANG IT'S
GOOD TO HAVE AN OPEN PRIMARY.
THIS TIME, LET LOW BLOWS FALL
WHERE THEY MAY, AND WE WILL GET
THE BEST CANDIDATE.
>> Jesse: WHEN BIDEN REALLY
NEEDS THE OBAMA ENDORSEMENT TO
COME HE CAN MAKE THAT PHONE
CALL.
RIGHT NOW, IT'S A LITTLE BIT TOO
EARLY FOR THAT TO HAPPEN.
WHEN BARACK OBAMA WAS THINKING
WHO IS GOING TO WIN MY THIRD
TERM, SOME OF MY LEGACY, HE
DIDN'T THINK ABOUT JOE.
WHO HAD BEEN WITH HIM FOR EIGHT
LONG YEARS.
THAT'S PRETTY SIGNIFICANT.
I JUST SAW THAT RALLY.
THAT REALLY WAS WEAK.
MAYBE -- THERE IS NOT A LOT OF
PEOPLE THERE.
THEY LOOKED BORED.
HE LOOKED LIKE HE WAS TRYING TO
COUNTERACT THE SLEEPY JOE
NARRATIVE THAT HAVE BEEN
FORMING.
HE WAS STUMBLING ALL OVER HIS
LINES, COULDN'T READ THE PROMPT
ARE WELL HE WAS STEPPING ON
THINGS.
HE JUST DID NOT LOOK POLISHED.
HE LOOKED EXTREMELY RUSTY, AND A
LOT OF THE PEOPLE BACK AND HAIR
AND MAKEUP SAID THAT HE HAD
FILLERS END.
BOTOX.
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN MAKEUP SAID
IT.
THEY LOOK AT FACES ALL DAY LONG.
I WILL SAY THIS, THOUGH, ABOUT
JOE.
HE CANNOT GET A CROWD.
ARE PEOPLE GOING TO DRIVE MILES
AND MILES TO LISTEN TO HIM?
ARE THEY GOING TO GET JOE BIDEN
TATTOOS LIKE THEY WOULD WITH
DONALD TRUMP AND BARACK OBAMA?
NO.
HE DOESN'T GIVE READINGS, SOLD
BOOKS, GET CLICKS.
THIS GUY IS A CANDIDATE BY
DEFAULT.
AND I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
THAT DEVELOP MORE AND MORE.
>> Juan: SO YOU DON'T THINK HE
GETS THE NOMINATION?
>> Jesse: I'M NOT SAYING THAT,
BUT I DON'T SEE THE EXCITEMENT
THERE.
THERE IS NO MOVEMENT.
THERE IS NOTHING THERE.
>> Juan: YOU SEE, I HAPPEN TO
DISAGREE.
IN FACT, BIDEN AND OBAMA GET
ALONG PRETTY GOOD, BUT DO YOU
THINK IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE?
>> Dana: I ALSO THINK IT COULD
HURT HIM.
THEY'RE ALL A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
THINK HE WAS NOT PROGRESSIVE
ENOUGH.
BIDEN IS GOING TO HAVE TO EXCITE
THE BASE IF HE CAN ON HIS OWN.
IN 2015 WHEN THE DECISIONS WERE
BEING MADE OF WHO IS GOING TO
RUN, JOE BIDEN HAD JUST LOST HIS
SON.
THAT WAS A VERY PUBLIC GRIEVING.
WE SHARED IN THAT GRIEF WITH
HIM.
IT COULD BE, THE HISTORY BOOKS
MY SHIRT WAS IN THE FUTURE, IF
PRESIDENT OBAMA EVER TALKS ABOUT
HER, WHAT HE WAS THINKING.
MY FRIEND, NOW MIGHT NOT BE THE
TIME BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT IN A
PLACE WHERE YOU CAN BE ABLE TO
CARRY A CAMPAIGN OFF.
I ALSO THINK THAT FOR OBAMA, HE
HAS ONLY ONE CHANCE TO BE A
KINGMAKER OR A PEACEMAKER.
WHY WOULD HE DO THAT NOW?
THEY HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO IN
HIS PRIMARY.
WE COULD ACTUALLY SEE A
CONTESTED CONVENTION BECAUSE OF
THE WAY THAT NEW RULES ARE, SO
HE COULD BE THE PERSON THAT
COMES IN AND SAYS THIS IS MY
PERSON, OR HE COULD SAY BETWEEN
THE TWO OF YOU, WERE GOING TO
WORK THIS OUT.
HE ONLY HAS ONE CHANCE TO DO IT.
>> Juan: DO YOU HAVE A
FAVORITE AMONG THESE DEMOCRATS?
>> Greg: OH, JEEZ.
NO.
[LAUGHS]
WHEN I WAS LOOKING AT THE RALLY,
THERE WAS A KEY MOMENT THERE.
WHILE HE WAS TALKING WITH THIS
YOUNG FELLA --
[LAUGHS]
OKAY, THAT'S HOW I FELT.
LOOK AT THAT.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS
JOE BIDEN'S FAULT.
I THINK THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
RUINED RALLIES AND POLITICIANS
FOR EVERYONE.
EVEN WHEN YOU HEAR A POLITICIAN
TALK AND THAT POLITICAL
SINGSONG -- OH, TALKING LINK TO
THIS.
AND THEN TALKING LIKE THIS.
IT SOUNDS SO FAKE BECAUSE THERE
IS A GUY TALKING TO YOU.
WHETHER YOU LIKE HIM OR NOT, YOU
CAN'T LISTEN TO POLITICIANS
ANYMORE BECAUSE HE'S DESTROYED
THAT WHOLE IDEA.
ALYSSA MILANO GIVE THE WORST
ADVICE.
SHE USE OF ALL THE DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES SHOULD PLAY NICE WITH
EACH OTHER.
NO CRITICISMS.
OKAY, YOU KNOW WHAT THAT'S LIKE?
THAT'S LIKE A FRIEND TO TELL YOU
BEFORE YOU TRAVEL TO SOME KIND
OF TROPICAL JUNGLE DON'T GET THE
INOCULATIONS.
YOU WON'T NEED THEM BECAUSE IF
YOU AREN'T INOCULATED TO THE
CRITICISM NOW, AND BEFORE E.U.
PHASE TRUMP IN THE JUNGLE,
YOU'RE JUST GOING TO GET EATEN
ALIVE BY EVERY BUG THAT YOU
WOULD NEVER RECOGNIZE.
>> Kennedy: ALL OF THESE
CAMPAIGNS ARE SO
PASSIVE-AGGRESSIVE.
SINGSONG AND SWEET TO EACH
OTHER, BUT THEN JUST PUT
HORRIFIC THINGS OUT.
>> Dana: IT'S GOING TO BE
GREAT.
>> Greg: ALYSSA MILANO IS NOT
A SHREWD POLITICAL ADVISOR?
SHE ZIGS AND ZAGS.
IF I HEAR TO POLICY POSITIONS
AND I CAN'T PREDICT THE THIRD
ONE, THAT SOMEBODY I'M
INTERESTED IN.
>> Juan: I THINK THAT'S WHY